Ja auf dem pixum whatsapp account da habe ich zahlreiche nachrichten bekommen die sich dieses thema gewünscht haben hier ist es
Also es ist möglich mit dem klonen der so ziemlich menschen ähnlichen spezies dem affen in china
Steht jetzt dem klonen von menschen nichts mehr
Im wege und die konsequenzen sind unglaublich und erschrecken wie sie aussehen und was das für die zukunft der menschheit
Bedeutet jetzt sind klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Im letzten tagen haben wir auf whatsapp über sehr viele dinge diskutiert
Und gechattet und ich habe darauf bin ich ein wenig stolz wirklich jede nachricht persönlich
Beantwortet die leute mit denen ich dort schreibe die können hier mal kommentieren um wie viel uhr
Sieben zum teil meine antworten zu bekommen haben im moment habe ich so noch
350 die ich noch beantworten muss die usa sind so ein bisschen meiner redaktion geworden deshalb
Habe ich das jetzt ausgebaut und man kann auch wirklich redaktionsmitglied werden und im skype konferenz und dem wirklichen
redaktionskonferenz mit über die themen bestimmen das wird haben wir das ganze wird über beiträge ab taschengeldniveau
auf patent möglich habe sicher inzwischen rund 50 wirklich klasse themenvorschläge dort bekommen vielen dank an dieser stelle schon mal den
mitgliedern ja und das thema, mit den geklonten affen das wurde dort immer wieder vorgeschlagen und heiß diskutiert denn die konsequenzen sind wirklich
Unfasslich 22 jahre nach. Dem klonen des schafes. Dolly in großbritannien ist das wirklich sensationelle
Gelungen zum ersten mal wurde eine spezies geklont die unserer so nah ist die von affen genauer handelt es sich um
langen schwanz makaken dieser affenart lebt in freier wildbahn in südostasien wird auf der ganzen welt bei tierversuchen eingesetzt
Um die beiden gekrönten äffchen zu erzeugen mussten mehrere hundert clown versuche unternommen werden bis es endlich gelang welche bedeutung
Dem versuch in china beigemessen wird das sagen die namen der beiden f king kong dong
Ich hoffe ich habe es richtig ausgebrochen und hua john hui heißt china man ist mächtig stolz auf dieses gelungene experiment
Im reich der mitte und in letzter zeit kommen immer mehr wissenschaftliche
erfolgsmeldungen von dort denn die chinesische regierung steckt inzwischen wie der westen milliarden in die forschung nur ist man dort
Skrupelloser so scheint es jedenfalls wir haben ja hier gerade erst über das frankenstein
experiment berichtet bei dem eine ratten menschen schimäre erschaffen wurde ein wirklich
Obskures mischwesen in china scheint mehr möglich zu sein warum also nicht menschen kloten wenn man sich das mal durch denkt ist es einfach
Gruselig ich könnte für ewige zeiten klickst du moderieren wenn ich sterbe
Moderiert es einfach ich also mein geklontes ich weiter es wird wahrscheinlich
Exakt genauso viel leidenschaft für wissenschaft haben wie ich wir würden immer wieder uns selbst als kinder kriegen und selbst können wir ja viel
Leichter vielleicht erziehen es wird ja wie in star wars clone armeen geben mit den besten geben für soldaten
ausgestattete superkämpfer immer und immer wieder geklont
herausragenden künstler kämen immer wieder auf die welt mozart beethoven bach oder heute justin bieber michael jackson madonna oder
sportler becker messi ronaldo
man könnte einen fußballverein der superlative aufbau die chinesen wollen da ja gerade durchstarten
Klonen würde da einiges vereinfachen es ist verrückt und
beängstigend zugleich zwar betont der leitende wissenschaftler von der chinesischen akademie der wissenschaften
zitat und theoretisch gilt wenn wir affen klonen können können wir auch menschen lohn dafür sehen wir allerdings keine notwendigkeit
auch ethische fragen verbieten uns das ja aber manchmal ist ein dementi die beste bestätigung
Bisher hat sich in der wissenschaft leider gezeigt was möglich ist wird auch gemacht als die erste atombombe gezündet wurde
Da war man sich, im vorfeld der forschung nicht
So sicher ob sie nicht einen weltenbrand eine
Entzündung der atmosphäre auslösen würde bei der alles zerstört würde
Ihr habt sicher das war nur geringe zweifel aber hätte man. Sich geirrt der bis heute keine menschheit mehr ich fürchte
also das vielleicht stand in den nächsten zehn jahren
geklonte menschen geboren werden man darf nicht vergessen dass gerade ein wettlauf zwischen der westlichen welt und china beginnt und der kann
Verheerende folgen haben wenn er als erstes neues zum thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt
ihr deutlich vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantierte könnte direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum mitmachen
und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen der
direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und hier geht zwar damit dafür auch draufklicken
frankensteins erben forscher erschaffen mensch platte mischwesen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran